les députés ont prolongé aujourd'hui en
commission l'aide au maintien à
l'agriculture biologique parce que ces
budgets ont été rognés 1
du budget gouvernemental bon allez c'est
toute la polémique du moment et tout ce
que vous allez rétablir ces aides
mais ces aides je n'ai pas lire et à
quel jeu ne sera supprimé elles ne sont
pas versées ng verser j'ai dû faire
n'arrivent plus dans les exploitations
ce n'est pas vrai j'ai dû faire un
transfert au coeur de l'été du pilier
inverse le pilier 2 qui a été très
commentée pour financer li chn
rapidement vont revenir
faisons pas besoin un peu de pédagogie
sur la bio oui mais voyez vous la
question que vous posez aujourd'hui elle
elle porte sur ce qui peut nous opposer
avec les membres ni les associations qui
promeuvent le bio et les allemands
aujourd'hui je n'ai rien supprimés nous
continuons à soutenir le je dirais la
mise en bio la conversion bien
évidemment nous avons dans le plfr
adopté un crédit d'impôt qui permet
aujourd'hui aux agriculteurs bio et 6 de
cela dont vous voulez parler qui permet
aux agriculteurs bio de pouvoir et bien
financer leurs activités financer leur
projet qui était de la responsabilité de
l'état ont été transférées aux régions
et discutons avec la rive plus dans dix
ans elle a voulu rassurer je les rassure
et je veux les rassurer en ayant des
questions à jean va s'en tenir aux
manuels et non parce qu'il faut dire des
choses avec avec la réalité non parce
qu'on ne peut pas laisser dire des
choses fausses mais justement on est
hors de question de dire que les aides
n'arrivent pas d exploitation ce n'est
pas vrai il y a les aides pac nous oui
mais il y a d'abord aux aides pac sur
lesquels nous avons travaillé les aides
mike qui arrivent dans les exploitations
puisque nous respectons le calendrier
que nous avions données et sur les aides
bio conversion crédit d'impôt nous
sommes au rendez vous est au rendez vous
on verra si vos propos rassure les
arguments julio est on le souhaite aussi
pour eux et pour ce qu'on a dans notre
assiette